the series game of thrones fans have
been waiting for house of the dragon the
prequel premieres august 21st on hbo but
g.o.t stand or not here are three
reasons to watch the spin-off
all right give me three words to
describe this series
very big dragons
reason number one it's a chance to watch
the crown's matt smith go from proper
prince philip to a scheming prince vying
for the iron throne i have decided to
name a new heir i'm your hair
reason two the special effects
they build this huge plinth basically
[Music]
and you're on it and you're like 20 foot
in the air and they harness you in and
then they fire a load of wind and rain
at you and after 10 hours you're like
look it's really fun for the first hour
but get me down
reason 3 this cast of mostly up and
comers is sure to win over fans just
like once unknown sophie turner kit
harrington and jason momoa did when game
of thrones premieres we've got this
amazing legacy that we want to uphold
did you reach out to anybody from the
original cast to find out what it was
like to do this i'm not just gonna like
slide into emilia clark's dms you know
what i mean like you just you can't
[Music]